with hundreds of thousands of cases and
over 14,000 deaths so far swine flu is
the latest global pandemic within weeks
of the Mexican government confirming an
outbreak in March 2009 cases of swine
flu were identified throughout the world
the virus that causes the flu h1n1
seemed to have emerged out of nowhere
but researchers contend that swine flu
shouldn't have blindsided public health
systems worldwide our experiences with
avian flu SARS and the West Nile virus
have taught us that there are certain
trends to how viruses emerge and these
could help predict and prevent outbreaks
in the future scientists have shown that
more than half of the infectious
diseases that affect humans originated
in animals HIV and malignant malaria
came from chimpanzees influenza A came
from wild birds and the plague was born
in rodents just to name a few the jump
from animals to humans often happens
through groups of people that have close
contact with animals like the bush meat
hunters in Central Africa
I traveled to Cameroon to see how
researchers from the global viral
forecasting initiative the gvf I are
working with bushmeat hunters to track
viral transmission Cameroon is what gvf
eye researchers call a viral hotspots a
place where the high biodiversity and
local way of life makes cross-species
transmission more likely the head of the
G BFI virologist Nathan wolf started
monitoring this viral chatter 10 years
ago wolf and his team work in rural
areas where the main source of protein
is wild meat rodents porcupines ant
eaters and non-human primates like
monkeys and chimpanzees after a kill the
hunters carry the meat back to the
village slung over their backs the blood
of the game runs down their legs and
mingles with their own the perfect
medium for viral transmission back in
the village preparing the fresh meat for
cooking is also a bloody affair and
another source of viral transmission in
a makeshift field laboratory the
researchers take blood samples from the
hunters and their prey so they can
search for viruses that have jumped into
humans they also take samples from other
species of wildlife to monitor the
general variety of viruses that are out
there in the forests of Cameroon some of
the samples are analyzed at the group's
new laboratory in Cameron's capital
yaoundé others are sent to top-notch
institutes around the world for special
analysis so far the group has shown that
monkey and eight viruses related to HIV
have jumped into Cameroonian hunters for
example around 1% of the hunters they
tested have been exposed to a retrovirus
called simian foamy virus but the group
hasn't shown that these crossover
viruses cause disease or spreading among
people in the last few years the gvf eye
has expanded its work and they now have
sampling centres in the Democratic
Republic of Congo China Malaysia and
Laos by providing a head start in
identifying viruses all over the world
the GV fi researchers hope to help
health officials intervene early to
prevent the emergence of pandemics like
swine flu in the future
you